cyberpunk 2077 is popular again taking a
look at the stream stats you can see a
100 increase in players over the past
month in fact it's the highest number of
players the game has had in the past
year according to CD projekt Red each
day of the week saw one million people
playing the game but why
okay let's be real I think we all know
the answer cyberpunk Edge Runners the
brand new Netflix anime based off of the
cyberpunk universe and created by anime
King Studio trigger Edge Runners added
much needed heart and helped fill in the
world of cyberpunk and you know what
it's a damn good show and all of this
delightfully animated by Studio trigger
Studio trigger made a splash immediately
when they hit the scene in 2013 with the
amazingly animated kill a kill and the
absolutely Charming little witch
Academia there's also patch 1.6 which
may or may not be contributing to it
I think it's all about Edge Runners why
am I Whispering this is my mouth so
let's talk about Edge Runners a little
bit cyberpunk Edge Runners follows the
story of David Martinez a straight A
student at the highly acclaimed and
expensive arasaka Academy a Surefire way
into the life of a corpo and the best
opportunity for most people living in a
world like uh like this
[Music]
okay this is where I'm going to pause
for a second there's going to be a lot
of terms here that anyone not familiar
with the world or game may not recognize
so here's a quick glossary so you won't
be a Gunk corpo is short for you guessed
it Corporation and a corpo is someone
who works for said corporations it's
also a life path you can pick up in
cyberpunk 2077 the world of cyberpunk is
hyper capitalistic with every single
thing costing Eddies and corporations
are essentially the ruling class Eddie's
as a side tangent are cyberpunk's
currency arasaka and militech are two
the universe's largest corporations who
are often at odds with each other we
have videos about it if you want more
info finally gonks as you might have
guessed are these cute little guys here
it also basically means idiot or [ __ ]
okay back to his runners
in this world the most affluent people
work for major corporations well it
seems like almost everyone else is
pretty much flat out broke David's mom
despite being a nurse can hardly afford
his education and they seem to run into
issues where they can't even afford to
do their laundry and all of this is
really one of the best things about the
show it has another level of personality
to cyberpunk 2077 that was sort of
missing while I enjoyed the main story
enough and definitely got into the
various side quests this was something
that felt missing from the game possibly
due to his unfinished State at release
whenever you look at the crowd or try to
interact the illusion of a bustling City
and crowds kind of falls apart the world
felt somewhat lifeless and thanks to the
show these gaps are filled in for you a
little bit it's nice to have this super
personal story about a struggling family
and it means that David ends up being
pushed to it's nice to see moments like
David walking through the slums and the
various characters minor interactions
hell there's a moment in the first
episode I'm about to spoil that makes
you really really think about your
actions in the game
again I'm about to spoil the first
episode so click to that time stamp if
you don't want that spoiler
David and his mom are driving home from
school after David has been put through
the ringer by the principal suddenly
there's a drive-by shooting and this
causes the pair to get into a major car
accident
[Music]
David's mom isn't treated by the trauma
team because they're poor and don't have
insurance while it's tragic in the story
the point is that this incident makes
you think a little bit more about the
general people living in the world of
cyberpunk it's okay to tune out that
sort of thing when you play these games
I definitely do that but it does help
make the world feel fleshed out
cyberpunk 2077 has a really cool world
that at times feels Hollow and this is
exactly the sort of flavor the world
needs to make it feel lived in another
great element of the show for me was
that it expanded on what I found to be
one of the more interesting aspects of
cyberpunk that ended up being relegated
to more of a side quest that of cyber
psychosis cyber psychos stem from
certain people implanting too much
Chrome into their Dome and eventually
losing control of their humanity and
themselves this show hones in on this
with its start being that of David
living out a brain dance of one of his
cyber psycho just like drugs
cybernetically enhancing oneself becomes
an addiction for some characters which
leads to their tragic downfall there's
also the fact that there's plenty of fun
Easter eggs to the game that if you play
the game you'll fondly remember and if
you haven't played the game then it'll
give you something to recognize when you
do play the game BDS or brain dances
you've got piled your beauty yet the
call noise characters are constantly
getting
[Music]
listen crawling through vents I mean of
course Adam Smasher
Bodyguard the afterlife bar
tonight City of course various
augmentations and weapons
and much much more in fact like many I
was inspired to go back and play
cyberpunk 2077 after watching as Runners
uh picking up my old save didn't go well
at first as I'd forgotten how to play
oh
but a crazy thing happened where I
hopped on a motorcycle and the first
song to play was this
[Music]
I didn't even realize the song was in
the game and then I bought it and now I
have it on my phone
while for me as Runners helped flesh out
cyberpunk 2077 from a story and personal
level a common sentiment I've seen on
Reddit is people playing the game to
help flesh out the world of edge Runners
and I think if that's what you want the
game will definitely do that I found it
interesting how little brain dances are
touched upon in Edge Runners while
simultaneously being a hugely important
aspect of the show for a little bit
meanwhile every detail about how brain
dances work how they're filmed and how
they're edited are a vital part of
cyberpunk 2077 with several missions
relating to this the afterlife which you
see a quick scene of Maine and dorio in
is an integral bar and part of cyberpunk
2077 which you can hang out inside of
but if that's not enough for you there's
the modding scene unfortunately I play
on PS5 so this is something I couldn't
experience
but if you want some sick mods to
replicate The Edge Runners experience
like getting David Martinez's haircut
which I wish I could do for my character
there's a mod of just that or how about
Lucy's face Rebecca's pistols or maybe a
radio station can choose with tracks
from the show YouTuber craze gaming made
a video on how to make David Martinez's
build in the game which I am definitely
in progress of doing I just gotta get
that sick hair mod so is it worth
finally picking up cyberpunk 2077 if you
never did or diving back into it if you
quickly hopped off well even playing on
version 1.6 and on a PS5 I'm going to be
honest with you I still experienced some
bugs although my recording failed and I
don't have it to show you for me it was
a dude just floating in the air that
said many of the major game breaking
bugs have supposedly been patched at
this point there's also a big expansion
coming in Phantom Liberty releasing in
2023 with much of the discourse being
people just hoping it's good and I know
for me my first time playing the game
was a little late to the party seven
months later to be exact and while I
experienced the bugs and found it was a
bit too much of a looter shooter in some
ways for me as opposed to focusing on
the RPG elements I still really enjoy my
time with cyberpunk and honestly Edge
Runners is just a great excuse for me to
pop back in again and make a video about
something that I really like I just hope
that we see more Edge Runners content
future and hopefully David Martinez's
haircut patched in as opposed to mod
because I want to be able to play it on
my PS5 come on CD project red
[Music]